merci monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président chers chers amis
donc il nous revient la joie l'honneur
et de vous présenter le budget 2016 tous
les cas ces grandes lignes alors qu'en
fait tu dis que ça marche
voilà ça y est donc qu'est ce qu'il faut
retenir du budget 2016 là c'est très
simple c'est un budget qui se
caractérise par la maîtrise des dépenses
que nous allons poursuivre par des
recettes que nous allons continuer à
stimuler par des relations avec les
fédérations qui vont être simplifiées
ce qui va nous permettre donc de
rembourser les échéances bancaires de
5,5 millions d'euros en mars 2016 et
c'est la deuxième fois nous allons
rembourser la dette vis-à-vis des
banques
nous allons aussi vous en regardez j'ai
regardé dans un instant quand tu à
rembourser l'emprunt nous avions
contracté auprès du groupe des
républicains la semaine nationale pas ce
qui va nous permettre aussi de financer
la primaire ce qui est important et
l'action politique très présidentiel
j'ajoute que c'est un budget qui est
conforme aux engagements que nous avons
pris avec les banques et c'est un budget
qui a été supervisé par un cabinet
d'audit indépendant qui a donc avalisé
ce que je vais vous présenter ce matin
en or des dépenses maîtrisées un budget
mobilier qui ne change pas puisque nous
louons à une sci nous nous sommes
d'ailleurs propriétaire les locaux de la
rue de vaugirard des charges de
fonctionnement qui sont globalement
stable à 4,7 millions d'euros et on
poursuit la politique nous avons mis en
place deux contient des dépenses
nouvelles
on essaye de les financer par des
économies nouvelles et par exemple ici
nous avons renégocié les contrats
d'assurance 20000 euros d'économies nous
avons renégocié aussi les règles sur les
reçus fiscaux 20000 euros d'économies
nous avons renégocié aussi les contrats
télécommunications et internet
40000 euros d'économie donc nous savons
de toute façon depuis un an
rencontré l'ensemble de nos fournisseurs
on a mis en place des appels à
concurrence et on a renégocié tous nos
contrats et ses économies ont permis de
financer le congrès de mai dernier le
conseil de ce matin qui n'était pas
prévu dans le budget est dans le cadre
du budget 2016 ces économies permettront
aussi de
financer un certain nombre de dépenses
nouvelles notamment de communication
propagande de sites internet et d'outils
vote électronique puisque la suite la
demande du président vous êtes désormais
consulter vous allez être de plus en
plus sur les conventions thématiques des
grandes orientations à prendre pour le
parti cela coûte de l'argent mais nous
l'assumons parfaitement grâce à cette
politique d'économie
ainsi quand ça les dépenses de personnel
nous étions tombés vraiment un point
très bas en 2015 à 78 équivalents temps
plein tant et si bien qu'ils avaient des
certains services qui ne pouvait plus
fonctionner dans des conditions normales
la direction des études y avait plus
qu'un directeur dont nous avons besoin
en 2016 pour préparer le projet la
plateforme pour l'élection
présidentielle d'un service d'étude qui
fonctionne de façon normale donc nous
avons pu à la suite de la renégociation
avec les banques dans un cadre financier
maîtrisé nous avons pu procéder à
quelques embauches très limité mais
qu'on va passer de 78 à 83 nous reste
très en deçà de 2014 où il y avait 80
cet équivalent temps plein évidemment de
2013 où il y avait 101 équivalents temps
plein et si on veut faire une
comparaison financière cette fois ci le
budget réservé au personnel sera de 19%
en retrait par rapport à 2013 mais tout
ça est très encadré très maîtrisée nous
avons souhaité parce que ça n'avait pas
été le cas depuis 2009
c'est vrai que mme ils sont moins
nombreux forcément bien la charge de
travail qui pèse sur eux est encore plus
forte et en dehors des directeurs bien
évidemment nous avons souhaité envoyer
un signal à l'ensemble des permanents et
de ceux à qui nous travaillons rue de
vaugirard en leur consentant une
augmentation très modeste vous
l'avouerez de 1,5 pour cent la première
depuis 2009 c'était important de montrer
aussi notre gratitude à l'égard de deux
de nos permanents et de les stimuler
pour pour l'avenir des dépenses
maîtrisées par conséquent des recettes
aussi stimulé nous avons un objectif de
don de 9 millions d'euros
il était de 7 millions 5 en
2015 et là je veux remercier tout
particulièrement le président nicolas
sarkozy parce que on serait absolument
incapable d'atteindre ses objectifs
s'ils n'étaient pas la tête de notre
mouvement dès 2014 sur le seul mois de
décembre on a fait un tiers un tiers ont
été ce chiffre parce que ça a été quand
même spectaculaire le président sarkozy
a été élu président en novembre 2014 et
sur le seul mois de décembre on a fait
un tiers des dons de l'année 2014 qui
nous a permis donc d'avoir un excédent
de 4 millions d'euros et en 2015 en 2015
c'est une date que j'ai bien en tête le
20 juillet 2015 ont dépassé la totalité
des dons de l'année 2014 et on est
maintenant en capacité d'atteindre nos
objectifs de 7 millions 5 et sans cela
on ne pourrait pas rembourser notre
dette aux banques et on ne pourrait pas
financer la primaire voilà donc un
objectif ambitieux mais nous allons nous
mettre en capacité de l'atteindre
les adhésions nous avons une prévision
raisonnable j'espère que nous là
dépasseront 2 5% d'augmentation par
rapport à 2015 les cotisations des élus
vous savez que c'est un sujet important
dans notre mouvement je tiens absolument
et vous tous et le président aussi à ce
que les élus payent leur cotisation
nous avons maintenant 100% des membres
du bureau politique qui payent leur
cotisation étions il y a un an à 20%
dont vous voyez que nous avons bien
progressé dans ce domaine il faut
continuer sachez aussi
sachez aussi que pour la première fois
pour la première fois nous allons
dépasser les prévisions de recettes dans
le budget 2002 15 s'agissant des
cotisations des élus donc les
cotisations rentrer il ya encore
quelques élus qui se font tirer
l'oreille
eh bien il faut continuer à leur mettre
la pression puisque nous avons à la
suite d'une proposition nathalie
kosciusko morizet modifier nos statuts
et il est clair qu'on ne peut pas ni
investir ni confie une responsabilité
dans le mouvement
un élu qui ne paye pas ses cotisations
ne peut pas demander des efforts aux
militants totalement les efforts aux
cadres étaient les élus se dispense du
paiement de leurs cotisations que les
choses soient claires les primaires nous
avons anticipé de recettes raisonnable
de 3 millions d'euros
mon avis on sera au dessus mais c'était
ce qui avait été imaginé en 2014 dans le
business plan et j'ai gardé ce chiffre
c'est un budget qui est évidemment
prudent et si nous dégageons un excédent
supérieur à celui que nous pensons ça
n'est pas grave ce que c'est ce qui
permettra de soutenir notre candidat
pour la présidentielle en 2017
et puis dès le premier des cent nous
allons lancer une boutique
alors elle est déjà ici présentes à
l'occasion du conseil décès nous avons
quelques produits nous allons très vite
étoffer la gamme et surtout nous serons
à partir du 1er décembre le seul parti
politique français à avoir une boutique
100 % made in france parce que oui c'est
une façon de soutenir les producteurs
français
alors du côté des relations avec les
fédérations simplifiée ça je tiens
absolument retenez bien cette
information parce qu'il faut qu'elle
passe dans les fédérations
on avait aujourd'hui derek hyper
compliqué selon qui il s'agissait d'une
adhésion d'un renouvellement des
cotisations d'élus là ils n'étaient pas
les mêmes
ce qui fait que personne et les
retenaient personne ne les connaissez
donc ce que je vous propose ce matin ce
n'est d'accord avec ce budget et avec le
soutien du président c'est une règle
très simple pour tout ce qui concerne
les adhésions et les cotisations des
élus c'est deux tiers/un tiers
et rassurez vous ces deux tiers pour
vous pour les fédérations et un tiers
pour nous une règle simple que vous
pouvez faire passer pour stimuler
évidemment ceux qui recherchent des
adhésions ou des cotisations s'est trahi
va s'appliquer aussi à la fédération des
français d'étrangers c'est une
revendication ancienne qui est
maintenant satisfaite j'ai rencontré le
trésorier la fédération des français et
étrangers vont être très très rapidement
cela en place mais aussi parce qu'il
faut soutenir nos jeunes qui sont
absolument formidable y en a dans la
salle et ils vous ont accueilli tout à
l'heure avec nous nous allons tripler la
dotation pour les jeunes républicains
alors ce budget avec des recettes
stimuler des dépenses maîtrisées va nous
permettre c'est très important de
rembourser les échéances bancaires de
5,5 millions d'euros en mars 2016 et
nous pourrons ensuite aussi bien
évidemment mars 2010 est remboursé cinq
millions 5 d'euros aux banques
c'est très important la situation
financière maintenant est assez dit est
assaini les comptes du mouvement sont
redressés nous avons pour la première
fois en 2015 commencer à rembourser
nous allons continuer en 2016 et en 2017
à la suite d'un accord conclu avec les
banques avec lesquelles nous avons
maintenant une relation de confiance de
transparence qui
voilà qui était nécessaire pour qu'on
puisse travailler dans un climat qui
soit apaisée et qu'on ait les moyens
aussi de mener nos actions en 2016 et en
il était prévu dans le business plan
négocié en 2013-2014 corrons 11 millions
d'euros
mais on n'aurait pas pu financer la
primaire et ans rémy se serait mis en
difficulté en trésorerie à la fin
d'année donc on a négocié 5 millions et
demi au lieu de 11 millions ce qui fait
qu'on montre un geste qu'on continue de
rembourser la dette mais en même temps
on a les moyens de fonctionner en 2016
et là aussi le président s'est impliqué
dans ce dossier puisqu'il a reçu avec
frédéric péchenard et moi même à deux
reprises des banques au siège je me suis
dit que maintenant on a une feuille de
route claire et des relations apaisées
et de confiance avec nos partenaires
bancaires et c'était important
un remboursement aussi en capital de 1
million d'euros en 2015 et en 2016 de
l'emprunt auprès du groupe les
républiques à l'assemblée nationale un
engagement que nous avions pris auprès
de christian jacob que nous venons et on
rembourse chaque mois là pour le coup et
35000 euros au groupe des républicains
de l'assemblée nationale ce qui fait
qu'à la fin de l'année 2016 la dette
globale s'élèvera à 62,4 millions
d'euros au lieu de 74 5 millions d'euros
31 décembre 2014 nous allons nous aurons
alors remboursé 12,1 millions d'euros et
face à ces 62,4 millions d'euros on a le
siège qui vaut environ 50 millions
d'euros devait que on a des garanties en
face de cette dette est évidemment
faudra continuer à rembourser ses dettes
mais on a une situation qui n'est plus
tendus comme elle était un certain
moment pour terminer dans le cas du
budget 2016
nous allons pouvoir financer une action
politique permanente un budget de 400
mille euros pour les déplacements et
réunions dans les fédérations
nous ne remboursons que les frais de
mission du président et de ses des
collaborateurs du groupe
mais pour le reste et c'est une
politique on a mis en place des
économies nécessaires
on demande aux uns et aux autres de
financer leur propre leurs propres
déplacements
je veux remercier le président parce
qu'il prend directement en charge
certain nombre de dépenses qu'il
pourrait se faire rembourser auprès du
groupe qu'il s'agit de déjeuner qui le
couple qui l'organisent rue vaugirard ou
à l'occasion de certains de ses
déplacements il ne le dit pas ça ne se
sait pas mais moi je tiens
aujourd'hui à le remercier parce qu'ils
n'hésitent pas à participer aussi de
cette façon redressement dans notre
mouvement nous avons prévu trois
conseils nationaux il y en avait quatre
prévus cette année on a pu grâce aux
économies réalisées en organiser 2 1 à 3
prévu pour l'année prochaine forcément
c'est une année évidemment clé la dpre
présidentielle et vie pour ce qui est de
l'action politique cyclique
on a pu dégager un billet un budget de
9.5 millions d'euros dont 5 millions
d'euros c'est important pour la primaire
donc n'auront pas besoin de faire appel
aux banques pour la primaire nous
pourrons prêté 5 millions d'euros à la
structure qui organisera à la primaire
je pense que c'était important d'arriver
à cet objectif
nous avons aussi prévu des dépenses
hauteur de 4 millions d'euros pour
l'organisation éventuellement d'un
campus
et puis aussi pour un éventuel congrès
d'investiture du candidat pour le parti
et pour des actions fin d'année 2016
après la primaire et si cet argent n'est
pas dépensé fin 2016 il viendra nourrir
évidemment l'excédent 2016 et pourront
le dépenser des mois de janvier février
2017 pour des actions qui permettront
donc de mettre en scène et de porter
notre notre candidat voilà alors en
conclusion je dirais que c'est un budget
qui est ambitieux qui est aussi
rigoureux qui est transparence avec eux
avec le président nous nous y tenons ces
questions financières mais je tiens à la
disposition de tous et je répondrai à
toutes les questions parce que je pense
que c'est important dans un parti
politique puisque nous utilisons de
l'argent public et l'argent des
militants et des donateurs c'est
important qu'on soit absolument
transparent on n'a rien à cacher je vous
le dis aujourd'hui ce matin très
clairement tous ceux qui veulent avoir
les comtés de détail des comptes
les oraux parce que dans un parti
politique on a en matière financière
rien à cacher je pense que c'est
important parce qu'il faut retrouver la
confiance de nos concitoyens des
militants et des élus dans le mouvement
et c'est par la transparence aussi qu'on
retrouvera cette confiance ce budget va
permettre aussi de financer la primaire
comme je voulais 10 et de préparer dans
les meilleures conditions les échéances
de 2010 est puisqu'on aura à la fois les
moyens de financer des actions tout de
suite après la primaire fin 2016 mais on
aura aussi grâce à l'excédent qui s'est
naturellement se dégagera les moyens de
financer dès janvier-février 2010 est
des premières actions pour soutenir
notre candidat pour l'élection
présidentielle
donc en conclusion je voulais remercier
le président sarkozy parce que comme je
voulais dit de par les fonctions qu'il
occupe au sein de notre mouvement il a
permis est largement facilité son
redressement à le remercier aussi pour
sa confiance parce que j'ai eu depuis
que je suis nommé un total soutien de sa
part
et c'est précieux et je tiens à vous
dire mais remercie aussi les membres du
comité financier c'était une proposition
nicolas sarkozy pendant sa campagne pour
la présidence du mouvement lé souhaitait
qu'on mette en place un comité financier
qui est composé à la fois demande du
bureau politique mais également de
militants tirés au sort et ce comité
financier je les réunis avant évidemment
de présenter le projet de budget en
bureau politique mardi dernier et avant
de vous présenter ce matin
je veux remercier les membres du comité
financier certains sont dans la salle
françois noël buffet il est ici je salue
caroline cayeux dino cinieri maïlys
courtois james courty johanna de souza
jean françois lamour arlette la ville
jacques lebigre isabelle quéval laurent
seillier et tokia saïfi vous pouvez les
applaudir parce que il faut un gros
travail aussi à mes côtés je remercie et
le bureau politique
les trésoriers départementaux qui font
un travail absolument formidable et
sachez qu'à partir du mois de janvier
tous les quinze jours je ferai un
déplacement dans les départements
notamment pour rencontrer les présidents
de fédérations les secrétaires
départementaux les trésoriers aussi que
c'est important je pense que le trésor
national eye aussi sur le terrain pour
débattre avec vous du fonctionnement de
vos fédérations
je remercie et frédéric péchenard parce
que c'est un formidable directeur
général et vous pouvez aussi l'applaudir
parce qu'avec lui je ne ferai rien
la direction des ressources l'ensemble
des permanents du mouvement qui jouait
simplement aussi en conclusion vous
remercier vous tous qui vous mettait
quotidiennement pour faire vivre notre
mouvement merci à vous